匠さん悩み事ありますか
ニキビがひどいですスゴれフォア
ニキビなんでできるかご存知でしょうか様々な要因があると思います寝不足油っぽい葉
も取りすぎちょっとた君がばお肌を気にしてるわけですよ
そんな感じのお金を改正しようと思って今日改変できるけ
[音楽]
一週間を1週間あれば変わるもしまぁ今日はそんな金のお肌を改善すべく
苫田クリスバラ専門の準備しましたこちらありがとうござい
こちら1ヶ月も釣れる論コラーゲ c ゼリー31ぽいリーヨ
というわけで匠さんニキビに困っていると思ってますそれくらいチラ見困ってますが
ずっと悩んでるんですけどいろんなやつ試したんですけど
聞かそんなた栗副社長なんですけどもコラーゲンというものをご存じでしょうかわかり
ますよ
プリプリしてるやつ
こちらコラーゲン c ゼリーというやつでえっとも書いてある通りコラーゲンが
77,500 mm 配合されております大丈夫か
なんかいついろいろ調べて結果これが俺の見た中では一番コラーゲの配合率が高かった
ためショット
そもそもコラーゲンとは大丈夫と厳密に言うとタンパク質のことでございます私たち体
を構成するのがタンパク質なんですけども7キャ
反駁して全然の30%30%近くがコラーゲンで作られていて簡単に説明すると体全体
の細胞の接着剤から接着剤みたいな役割をしていますそしてその後ラーゲなんと肌に
多く含まれていまして
だから肌にいいって言われてください
いや大丈夫大丈夫って俺がなんとすれば今日本当に
昔ですけどちょっと悪かったって笑ってるでしょ肌改善にはいろんな方法があると思う
んですけども
まず彼にはまずは栄養ですね体の事になるものからまず改善していきたいというわけで
コラーゲンのゼリー20本を準備しました
1ファッカー第7番では1500mg コラーゲンが入っているので7万なら
1500mg かける20
155万ミリグラムのコラーゲンが箱
始めます g 3なおずっと1550g
1.5キロこちらにはボランティア損する質問です
じゃあ類さんとりあえずカードトゥではなかった笑っていいねぇよ行うような清書して
みましょう
まずはカードの中からキレイになってもらおうという企画でございますできて今回は
下げ55万ビリグラムのコラーゲンを摂取してもらおう
行け行け起きるお肌のためなはなるべくフェスしてもらって肌の変化を見ていき
ましょう
よく食べていきましょうよし
台座やアイ1本飲むためにも1500mg のコラーゲンが巧みな肌に収入されてきた
いただきますどうぞ
[音楽]
美味しいかも知れほんとよろしいこれああなにそれなら全然ある意味でに行ける
温度グンソクラフためレゲエもう
ています
あおいしいんじゃなくてことはい早くももう10000mg 行きました
色黒の色がすごい
[音楽]
trek まつがいた実家に送っちゃって立てよ数を課す21個の端でしょ
持った洋白お母さんに取られるんだろう
グループから募った
マゾいるまだ大丈夫大丈夫ななんかはなにか
著者がちょっと
はい5番ミリグラム達成ですません
素晴らしい7万7000500mg 1か月で主よねー
ええっ
皆さんにかけずですエアーいっ
[拍手]
俺がゼリーを食うかゼリーに食われるかの闘いなことわざ
言葉が流暢に話せていない
はーとぼっ
[音楽]
102,500
大丈夫です高いぞうんて高層猫ちゃん
は嬉しいなぁ
含めはず紅霧の討伐数だからね俺も何とかしようと思ってたどり着いてはまだ大好き客
がこちらなんだよ
97,500を一袋を行けばついに
ズーマいきましたーーーズブ f なんのことかね
おおーー
ちょいな40日分流石っすよ凄いぜマン2500で素晴らしい今日外は内周には肌が
綺麗なというふうに思いません
匠
[拍手]
[音楽]
ん
l
[音楽]